once upon a time people wrote this way
you couldn't even buy a vowel
someone had to invent them it might have
happened something like this Greece no
not that Greece Greece before there was
a Parthenon a stern old man in a
trademark sporty toga seems a bit on
edge as he glares at the papyrus sheet
clutched in his hand
ah you see you try to shrug off his
outburst but he can't let this go my
friend my friend he recounts how five
hundred years before he was even born
when the walls of Troy still stood the
Greeks had a writing system of their own
it was one of those more elaborate
syllabary plus logograph types but that
script had come and it had gone the new
Greeks were people on the rise but an
illiterate people on the rise a people
looking for something new something
great and this alphabet thing seems
great almost he calls over his close
friends the Phoenician consonants are
useful he concedes but why these extra
characters for huffing coughing and
clearing your throat
these are barbarian sounds Greeks have
no need for them and what about the
voicing noises like ah and whew how to
write them huh so much extra yet so much
missing what a mess you try to explain
but they laugh it off
here I fix for you he says see he was
going to ditch see mm-hmm barbarian
letters but he had second thoughts and
it struck him why not use these on Greek
sounds for vowels
the one you call LF ignore the throaty
catch at the beginning its ah take that
hey
but ditch the huh and we're left with a
vowel e a loosen up that tight wah
in Wow and it's the vowel mmm this isn't
just a small correction this is a
powerful major moment in the history of
writing he's fundamentally shifted the
way the alphabet functions it used to be
just the consonants suggesting the
pronunciation of a word once you
recognize the word the jobs done
but Greek spelling isn't merely about
writing recognizable words it's about
matching letters to sounds a new
principle has just emerged perhaps even
a new goal one sound one character you
suspect that he's not even aware of the
impact of his discovery as he tells you
to drop everything and come enjoy some
dinner and dancing
who'd be silly the party goes on and on
so long that your new friends don't even
see what's happening beyond the walls of
their city-state this consonant vowel
alphabet this pronunciation writing is
spreading inspiring new alphabets to the
east with flavors like Armenian and
Cyrillic popping up out west in Italy
the Tuscans the Etruscans borrow it and
they pass it on to the Romans the Romans
burst out and splatter it among the
celts and germanic peoples and
eventually the world such a visual
rainbow of variations and yet they'll
all stick with the basic principle of
writing a character for each sound
consonants and vowels finally you see
your writing system in this story your
alphabet all because a handful of
semitic symbols got mistaken for greek
vowels but before you get overconfident
know that the history of writing doesn't
stop here this isn't the be-all and
end-all not even close
you